[Music]
everybody's got a theory about Jon Snow
is he coming back oh my god I mean
people lost their minds when he died
women in the office smashed all the
furniture and and and just went crazy
yes they were so upset hey what was that
when he died
when he dies no that's just any time I
enter the room so upset to see me no
yeah when he died they're just so sad
yeah I mean I mean people say what if
what effect will Jon Snow going have on
the show means that we'll we'll have our
viewership because all the women are
gonna stop watching yeah but yeah there
are a lot of bizarre theories about it
there's certain theories that what's the
theory you're hearing a lot oh the one
that I'm hearing the most is that he's
gonna come back in the form of an animal
mm-hmm like so it is gonna be the
character but he's gonna be in the body
of a direwolf or something yeah which is
a strange theory but because what you're
really asking yourself there is do they
like the character of Jon Snow enough
that they're gonna want to see it being
played by a dog I mean kit harington
sure he won't mind me saying this he's
got a very marketable face he's a very
very good-looking guy carries a lot of
sex appeal I'm not sure that a dog is
gonna carry that same thing and if it
does those people go ask themselves some
serious question yeah just having a dog
running around with his voice yeah as
Jon Snow that's not gonna do it for
people yeah I don't think that's a good
idea it would be pretty great be pretty
funny talking dog yeah it shouldn't do
people children if those people can get
their kicks elsewhere
you